Getting sick and having absolutely no way
to prevent it from happening: not ideal.
While the medical community has made huge
strides in understanding how pathogens cause
disease and developing treatments to fight
against infection, detecting airborne viruses
and preventing them from entering our bodies
remains unreasonably difficult.
And by difficult, I mean virtually impossible,
because there’s not a whole lot to protect
us when we breathe.
But there's hope—and it comes in the form
of our fourth state of matter, plasma.
Engineers just demonstrated a proof of concept
plasma reactor that inactivated or removed
99.9% of a test virus from the air in a fraction
of a second
Prized for its powerful disinfecting qualities,
plasma has found applications in plenty of
industries to chemically extract particles
from the air, but using it to target viruses
is a totally novel application.
Viruses are the most abundant biological entity
on Earth, and some of them, like measles and
the common cold, travel by way of sneezing,
coughing, and breathing.
And do they travel.
Sneezes can launch germs up to 8 meters in
a matter of minutes, where many can remain
alive in the air for hours.
There’s even a theory that viruses are able
to hop on the backs of dust and soil particles
and coast around the world on high-altitude
air currents.
The global air purifier market is projected
to reach approximately 6.2 Billion U.S. dollars
by 2023, so clearly this is a thing.
And if you have one at home, it’s probably
either one that's designed to trap particles
in a filter, or deactivate them through a
chemical reaction.
All have their downfalls.
Electronic air filters like electrostatic
precipitators can be efficient for extracting
particles, but they don't remove gases and
smells and can produce harmful by-products.
Mechanical systems, like HEPA filters, can
have difficulty capturing and removing all
pollutants that enter an indoor space, especially
one that's not air-tight.
They also tend to have trouble with microorganisms
and bacteria bypassing the filter.
Another type of air purifier, like ozone generators,
are specifically designed to deactivate or
destroy pollutants.
But they actually just release an inorganic
molecule that’s a toxic component of smog.
So what makes plasma so promising?
Let’s break it down.
First observed by Sir William Crookes in 1879,
plasma is the fourth state of matter after
liquids, gases, and solids.
It's comprised of a cloud of free-flowing
ions, or electrically charged atoms, but the
cloud itself has no overall charge.
While plasma exists when molecules are heated
to extremely high temperatures, it can also
occur at room temperature if the molecules
are exposed to a strong electrical field.
This is known as cold plasma, aka non-thermal
plasma, and it’s the kind we want to use
if we want breathable air—I mean, normal
plasma could make things clean too, we just
can’t breathe air at that high a temperature.
Now, just to be clear, plasma is already being
explored by industries to take pollutants
out of our air and water.
But using plasma to rip viruses apart?
That’s a whole new ball of electrons that
engineers at the University of Michigan just
unraveled.
Using a cold plasma reactor, they were able
to inactivate or remove 99.9% of a test virus
from their experimental airstream in a fraction
of a second.
It works like this: as the virus flows into
the reactor pipe, a large voltage is introduced
to create an electric discharge, or spark.
A bed of dielectric beads sandwiched between
the electrodes maintain the spark of plasma,
whose unstable atoms oxidize the virus as
it moves through the pipe.
Upon exiting, the virus is merely a shell
of its former self—with an extremely diminished
capacity for infecting a host.
However, it’s not entirely clear how cold
plasma works to inactivate viruses: it could
be that the presence of the electric field
causes their shells to expand and rupture,
or that the fragments of the air molecules
chemically attack them.
But hey, it works.
This successful proof of concept holds a whole
lot of promise for putting the brakes on airborne
viruses.
It combines both air purification and inactivation
of airborne pathogens, making it a more effective
option for disease control than the air filters
we currently have.
The University of Michigan team has already
begun trialing cold plasma’s effectiveness
at nearby livestock farms, where the risk
of animals contracting airborne viruses is
extremely high.
Because if we breathe 3,400 gallons of air
per day, it’d be great if it were virus-free.
And we humans breathe a lot, an average of
3,400 gallons per day.
Did you know that sneezes can launch germs
up to 38 yards per second?
If you want to learn more about viruses, check
out Sick,
Don’t forget to subscribe for more Seeker.
I’ll see you next time, thanks for watching.